all right guys it's christmas morning
and we set it up as if santa claus
stopped by
check it out let the man know
he ate his cookie his reindeer even ate
the celery
but we want to see tyka's reaction
what
that's crazy
that's crazy
did you hear santa claus last night
yeah i heard other steps you heard steps
what whoa and i knew that's cute you got
a present already up there yeah
that's cool
what
whoa
what's that
hey it says dear taika
thank you for the milk and cookies santa
claus
[Applause]
wait come here come here you can open it
over here we're gonna open over here
okay
that's cute
[Music]
wow that's a big one
hey don't open them yeah we're gonna
move them all over first no yeah you can
open it okay okay let's see what this
one is a car
a car
what
is that the one you wanted
a car
hey that's so cool
all the presents have his name on it
it's like uh
look at blue
wow
holy moly
because it's cute okay open that one
okay okay i have my name yeah has your
name on it
what's going on back there oh
okay what's in that one
let me see let me see what it says can i
see what it says yeah okay let's see
it says
ginormous hatching grow
just add water oh you add water and a
dinosaur grows and comes out
that's cool huh
this flat one this flat one okay this is
cool
i have it high i'm gonna open this
oh
oh
there you go
wow that's cool ninja turtles
wow this is so cool what is this
okay thank you
thank you for telling me
over here give me the dress it's okay
don't worry about it
don't worry about it i'm just picking
them up santa is a good guy
santa's a good guy
he's good huh he's a good guy
you like him he's a good dude huh he's
the best
[Applause]
a guy
what
that's cool
with targets hey that's awesome hell
yeah target practice
[Applause]
that is really cool
[Music]
i know maybe he knew you were good this
year
[Applause]
another flat what that sounds like
chocolates
what does it sound like chicken what do
you think is inside
[Applause]
this thing is healthy
[Applause]
whoa
what this is
right there oh this is a science one
this one's cool
yeah
yeah yeah
what is this one
whoa let's see the other side it says
human body
you could be a doctor it could be a
surgeon a human body
oh that's awesome
there's a huge body
look at the skeleton it is yeah
i need a body you can practice being a
good asian doctor
well look
[Applause]
it does say it
what is it
how do you think santa claus knows you
like spiderman that's crazy
[Applause]
wow how does he know you like spider-man
that's crazy bone
taika got another gift from ryan of
ryan's world that says hi taika we heard
your big ryan world fan so we uh hope
you enjoy these ryan world galaxy
explorer toys happy holidays
you did let's see what's in here
whoa
ryan's toys
whoa you have the the presents still
keep coming
all right
this guy had such a blast opening all
his toys
this morning he had so many toys we're
playing with the marble thing there's so
many guns silly putty but now it's time
for you to take a nap oh yeah and he's
been really good at this i think because
of school helped him or they have a
regularity nap so we try to stick to
that schedule they done monkey cheeto
right there put in a little spot
put down the putty
hey what's going on dude you don't need
a cube go over there sit over there hey
okay here's your mr milk
go over here i already set it up for you
i'll bring the blanket
this guy is crazy
what's crazy is he goes from that in
like under 10 minutes
christmas
so the fun thing about all these toys
is that you get a lot of toys
the not fun thing is
putting everything away
but taika is really good he's a good boy
and before he could play with more toys
although you got to put some of this
stuff away
by the way
i never knew you
ryan from ryan's world that you were
such a second amendment advocate
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah
they come up from up here
anyways back to ryan this dude i didn't
know he was such a
pro second amendment guy
because one he makes sniper rifles
so he has sniper rifles
and he also makes fully automatic
weapons
and his magazines
let me see
pull this out pull on the plastic the
the red one pull it up
this thing holds more than 10 rounds
which is not california compliant at all
good thing i'm in nevada
but man i didn't know ryan was such a
pro-gun dude we got sniper rifles
automatic weapons
and he also has a giant pistol too shout
outs to you ryan thank you for
supporting the gun community i'm not
even in the gun community i'm just
observing
all right so we gotta wash our blankets
and i'm being lazy
i don't want to go upstairs i'm gonna
see if i can throw it to mama up there
this house is ridiculous it should not
be this big
it should not be as big ready yeah
[Applause]
oh my god
go
what do you think for the bed
oh so close okay guys
okay
ready
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
you're the best
okay
that's the way to do it
so now it's time for tyka to give us the
gifts that he bought us
who's going first okay
hey this is nice
good job
[Applause]
there's something yummy they're giving
me clues
candy
ooh dinosaurs
yummy yummy how can we get those for
papa
yummy
oh okay what about my present where's my
present
so what do you think about the present i
think it's cuny
dinosaur haribo dinosaurs yeah that's
cuny are you okay
okay i'm ready for my gift
okay i feel like it's gonna take a
minute
okay special delivery
[Applause]
i'm ready for my gift
[Applause]
i wanted to take a picture of it
before you open it i want a picture okay
oh he's coming back
we need to document these here
thank you
what
nice
wait you don't want to see me open your
gift
[Applause]
what it okay ready
wow spiderman
oh
what is this for you what do i do how do
i use it
amazing thank you
oh can we take a picture
yeah and then i gotta go okay go first
and then we'll take a picture where's
you gotta go i don't know i got hair
clipped excuse me
i went with him to buy it yeah and i was
like okay what are you gonna get papa
and he showed me that and i was like
okay i'm like what about
mama and then
okay
this dry erase i'm only using a special
marker okay
okay
i don't know if you can see anything
this is worth
10 points
yeah this is worth 30 points what
this is worth 40 points whoa
that's a loss
series okay so you can't fall no ten
points is that you want to get it here
this is a lot of points this is 40.
yes you want to get it in so your goal
is to get it in here okay okay
okay you go first
20 points
[Applause]
oh okay all right
behind this line
are you kidding me
go you
why is he doing trick shots
[Music]
keep going don't do that
good job dude
whoa
[Applause]
that's insane
[Applause]
[Music]
all right baby
whoa 10 points
oh
yeah wow 70 90
110.
what
130
what who do you got look i know you want
to play no no i'm okay you want to play
i don't want to crush you guys
questions
130.
[Music]
can you pick him up for me little rude
guy
no you don't i did five okay i called it
this guy's next i can't see i can't he
doesn't want it monkey thank you thank
you for the safety
i know he thinks he's uh wait wait wait
let's see
okay go
oh man i can't see anything
20.
sorry baby
50. wow
i'll give it to you
hold that monkey hold that monkey
you got two more peppa
wait wait wait wait
what's happening
i got two more let me start over no
cheater what the hell
no because it's not cool too bad dude
this is real life
no wait get out of the fire zone get out
of the fire
wow
okay so you got 150 170. 190. oh why the
other one hit that exactly yeah but that
but it did it it doesn't count does it
count
if you if a bullet goes in a previous
hole well this is not a boat that's how
accurate that is
have you ever watched robin hood well he
splits arrows
hey have you
robin okay fine you get 190. my turn one
my turn
this is war baby
yeah yeah yeah
duty
yeah what is this what is this
headphones
this is so uh what are they for papa
what are they for so we're gonna go
shooting tomorrow and i want to start
bringing taika into like the whole like
gun world and stuff so i want to make
sure i protect those little ears
i got look what i got you too
little eye pro too
eye phone no eye pro eye protection eye
protection look at that what is that
let's protect your eyes so you can see
wait why would you put it on your head
why their little head
who does glasses oh my god no no this
one's the reason these are the good ones
the good good ones let's see look at
that whoa
stud
stud
put them on yeah they're going to be
hard to put on tell papa to put them on
for you
did you just call your dad a little
dumpster yeah poop
no not funny
there you go
why are you ready it looks like a like a
flight controller he does he's like
like this okay
do what papa's telling you to do
it matches it's the same green as this
astronaut suit you cutie pie
[Applause]
all right
so now to the not so fun part the clean
up after the big party today but taika
you got so many cool toys
i'm so happy for you
oh hey
but yeah he's cleaning everything up so
all the new toys are not gonna be
introduced to this pile of junk because
there's a lot of toys here
that are broken and that he no longer
plays with so before integrating the new
stuff and adding to this mess before the
year is over ty and i are going to look
at all his toys and we're going to throw
away what he doesn't play with and what
what's broken like this he hasn't played
with this in like a couple years so i do
okay dude
um whoa so that'll what will be
happening
not tonight tonight it's already 9 20.
oh my god dude it's way past your
bedtime we're gonna just wrap it up down
here call it a night
hope you guys had a beautiful wonderful
holiday and if you didn't
don't worry about it
it's only temporary things will get
better
and there's only sunshine and rainbows
from this point on right
okay well have a great day see you
tomorrow